[Musique]
bonjour nouvelle édition du 7 8
politique dédiée chaque semaine aux
campagnes des élections départementales
dans les yvelines et régionales en
ile-de-france nous débutons par les
régionales cette liste se présente les
candidatures officielles viennent donc
d'être déposé en préfecture et comme
vous le savez peut-être chaque
département a sa propre liste de noms
qui pourront siéger dans l'hémicycle
régional le point complet avec eléonore
sinoquet c'est officiel depuis lundi 17
mai au soir les listes pour les
élections régionales ont été
officiellement déposée en ile-de-france
cette liste vont concourir pour la
gouvernance de la région capitale tour
d'horizon des têtes de listes candidat à
la présidence mais aussi des postulants
yvelinois valérie pécresse repart
présidente du parti libre et présidente
sortante du conseil régional elle est
candidate à sa réélection avec la liste
ile de france rassemblée elle est
également tête de liste dans les
yvelines
à ses côtés dans le département pas de
changement othman nasri premier vice
président sortant et conseiller
municipal d'opposition à trappes se
place en deuxième position suivi
d'alexandra dublanche adjointe au maire
à sartrouville est elle aussi
vice-présidente sortante du côté de la
majorité présidentielle c'est le député
du val de marne et rapporteur général du
budget à l'assemblée nationale lors en
sang martin qui conduira la liste envie
d'ile-de-france pour la république en
marche dans les yvelines il a investi
jean-noël barrot député modem de la 2e
circonscription en tant que tête de
liste
aurore bergé député de la 10e
circonscription se place à la deuxième
position
à gauche l'ancien journaliste et
actuelle adjointe au maire d'anne
hidalgo à paris audrey pulvar se lance
dans la bataille des régionales avec la
liste ile-de-france en commun investie
par le parti socialiste
elle a choisi d'y naba diop porte parole
du ps dans les yvelines et conseillère
municipale aux mureaux pour représenter
sa liste dans le département en deuxième
position ce sera eddie aït maire de
carrières sous poissy et conseiller
régional sortant
pas d'alliance avec le ps dont pour
europe ecologie les verts le conseiller
régional sortant et secrétaire nationale
du parti écologiste julien bayou se
présente à la présidence de
l'ile-de-france avec l'écologie
évidemment pour les ter yvelinoise jyske
anne sonnet conseillère régionale
sortante et ancien maire des vêtements
sera tête de liste en numéro 2 benoît
hamon de génération ancien député des
yvelines et ancien candidat aux
présidentielles
il a préféré e élevés plutôt que le ps à
l'autre bout de l'échiquier politique le
rassemblement national jordan bardella
vice-président du parti de marine le pen
mais aussi député européen et conseiller
régional sortant a présenté sa liste le
choix de la sécurité dans les yvelines
pas de surprise le responsable 60,18 du
parti frontiste
laurent maurin et tête de liste suivi en
troisième position de cyril notre ancien
maire de mantes-la-jolie seules communes
d'île de france affilié rassemblement
national entre 2014 et 2020 à l'extrême
gauche de liste d'abord pouvoir vivre en
ile de france celle de la france
insoumise avec clémentine autain député
de la seine-saint-denis allié au parti
communiste français la liste investi
nelly duthu ancien maire de la verrière
et membre du comité exécutif du pcf
comme tête de liste yvelinoise sébastien
ramage conseiller municipal elle est
fille à lui en cours sera son numéro
deux enfin la septième et dernière lice
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
et celle de nathalie arthaud porte
parole de lutte ouvrière dans les
yvelines jean pierre mercier l'ancien
candidat lutte ouvrière aux municipales
2020 à poissy et tête de liste en numéro
2 une factrice à la retraite hélène
janis est debout la france jette donc
l'épongé pour ce scrutin et dans notre
région le parti de nicolas dupont aignan
a expliqué ne pas pouvoir assumer je
cite le surcoût très important entraînée
par le contexte sanitaire
on notera néanmoins que sa propre
suppléante à l'assemblée figurent sur la
liste du rassemblement national lisa
haddad fait d'ailleurs partie des
quelques 130 cadres de la formation à
avoir démissionné il ya quelques mois en
disant regretter l'isolément de nicolas
dupont-aignan sur l'échiquier politique
sur le terrain à la campagne est en tout
cas bel et bien lancée ainsi valérie
pécresse s'est rendue dans son
territoire des yvelines afin d'évoquer
la ruralité
le reportage est signée julien frenoy
matt eastwood droit et astrid bergère à
un mois des élections régionales valérie
pécresse s'est rendue dans plusieurs
villages des yvelines jeudi 13 mai
accompagné de
larcher est lee a dévoilé les grandes
lignes de son programme pour le milieu
rural
nous voulons l'égalité pour le rural
l'égalité pour les habitants de tous ces
territoires pour que les habitants des
territoires ruraux et un meilleur accès
à la santé une meilleure sécurité
un meilleur accès aux commerces plus
d'emplois plus de transport parmi les
propositions de la candidate la
construction d'un nouveau lycée dans le
canton jude en bonne hier valérie
pécresse propose aussi d'élargir
l'enseignement supérieur au sein des
lycées
notre objectif c'est que dans chaque
lycée rural il puisse y avoir des bts
des classes préparatoires des licences
professionnelles donc de des
possibilités de poursuite d'études
qu'ils soient offertes dans chaque lycée
rural d'île de france
un nouveau mandat que valérie pécresse
souhaite aussi axé sur le numérique
nous continuerons le programme un
ordinateur par lycéen et par enseignant
pour que tous nos lycées soit 100%
numérique
nous voulons que tous les villages soit
fibres et ce sera le cas dans les
yvelines à la fin de l'année tous les
villages seront fibrées nous voulons
évidemment déployer la 5g partout donc
l'idée ce sera qu'on puisse travailler
télétravail et de son village
créer son entreprise dans son village
malgré ces changements en milieu rural
la candidate entend conserver l'identité
des villages nous allons mettre 50
millions d'euros sur la rénovation du
patrimoine dans le prochain mandat pour
continuer à rénover des dizaines
d'églises de l'avoir de ferme de maisons
des illustres qui font évidemment l'âme
de nos villes et de nos campagnes et
valérie pécresse souhaite que de pouvoir
d'achat des franciliens restent
inchangés sauvegarder l'identité village
tout ça ça se fera en préservant le
pouvoir d'achat des habitants de la très
grande couronne comment est-ce qu'on
préserve le pouvoir d'achat mais d'abord
tout ce qu'on propose en le finançant
hausses d'impôts évidemment les
élections régionales auront lieu les 20
et 27 juin prochains à valérie pécresse
qui reste pour l'instant en tête des
sondages mais qui pourrait se retrouver
dans une situation délicate en cas de
second tour face à la gauche au
rassemblement national et à la
république en marche surtout en cas de
forte abstention lors de cette
quadrangulaire le parti présidentiel a
lui annoncé refuser dans tous les cas
une alliance avec valérie pécresse est
lui aussi occupe le terrain laurent sam
tu as envoyé à sa tête de liste dans
notre département jean-noël barrot a
abordé la question des transports lors
d'un déplacement que nous avons suivi
nicolas kirillovitch c'est toujours le
même nerf de la guerre en ile de france
les transports reste l'une des
préoccupations majeures des habitants
dans les zones rurales plus qu'ailleurs
l'accès aux mobilité limitée pour la
majorité présidentielle et c'était de
liste yvelinoise l'urgence se trouve
dans l'offre de nouveaux services
il faut qu'ils aient de l'équité
territoriale on peut pas avoir une
différence de service alors qu'on paye
les mêmes en co dans le sud yvelines par
rapport au nord des yvelines dans les
yvelines par rapport à d'autres
départements voire même plus donc on a
vraiment besoin d'avoir cette équité
territoriale la gratuité des parcs
relais ça je crois que c'est vraiment un
point qui est essentiel dans le sud de
notre département et aussi les services
qu'ils soient sécurisés qui soit propre
qu'il soit beau qui donne envie en fait
tout simplement aux usagers de venir
autre priorité pour la liste menée par
laurent saint martin de la sécurité le
candidat centriste souhaite créer une
police régionale pour les lycées les
transports et donc c'est abdiquer donc
là il ya 90 places mais on a encore la
capacité de pouvoir développer la partie
supérieure à proximité de la gare de
saint rémy les chevreuse ce parking à
vélos fermé et protéger des infractions
nous avons subi depuis le début du
confinement et même avant cela un
certain nombre d'actes d'incivilités de
cambriolage grâce à mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre de la gendarmerie des
yvelines
nous avons pu faire reculer cette
délinquance qui empoisonnait le
quotidien des commerçants de saint rémy
et nous devons rester vigilants et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous proposons
une police régionale dans les transports
qui permettra à tous les franciliens de
circuler en toute sécurité et pour les
gars de bout de ligne comme ça rémy les
chevreuse et bien de faire échec à la
des lacs aux transports en commun vélo
mais aussi voiture la république en
marche et ses alliés en ile de france
veulent augmenter les aides pour l'achat
de véhicules électriques
les particuliers par exemple pourrait se
voir ainsi financer jusqu'à 70% du
montant de leur nouvelle voiture
le rassemblement national se présente en
ile de france derrière jordan bardet
l'un et dans les yvelines pour porter ce
programme
en tant que tête de liste programme
principalement axé sur la sécurité ce
sera donc laurent morin est le
responsable départemental de la
formation lepéniste ancien premier
adjoint de mantes-la-ville entre 2014 et
on notera par ailleurs qu il s'est aussi
engagé dans la campagne des
départementales il figure aux côtés de
monique fureur sur le canton de
bonnières sur seine
il sera mon invité pour l'entretien
politique fin mai sur tv 78 évoquons à
présent les départementales dans le sud
des yvelines dans le plus grand canton
du département celui de rambouillet
quatre listes s'affrontent comme
ailleurs difficile de faire campagne
surtout dans un territoire elle très
rurale en raison de la situation
sanitaire
elle les candidats tentent néanmoins
d'aller à la rencontre des électeurs
lors des marchés en fin de semaine
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
steban quatre binômes en lice pour le
plus grand canton des yvelines celui de
rambouillet la campagne pour les
élections départementales a démarré
samedi dernier les candidats sillonné le
territoire du sud yvelines pour
présenter leurs idées
à l'image du binôme clarisse demont et
geoffroy backs de keating candidat sur
la liste ensemble pour les yvelines de
la majorité sortante
on a un attachement qui est très fort en
tant qu'élu du territoire on a un
attachement très fort au sud yvelines
est ce qu'on souhaite c'est vraiment le
préserver aujourd'hui on a beaucoup
d'urbanisation en ile-de-france qui
s'approchent au fur et à mesure vers le
sud yvelines
est ce qu'on souhaite c'est tous
ensemble faire bloc pour protéger ce
cadre de vie
c'est tous ces trois thèmes on va dire
préserver tout en innovant
harmonieusement pour l'environnement
sans oublier évidemment les services au
plus près de la population
parmi les projets du binôme ep y un bus
médical pour répondre aux besoins des
déserts médicaux du canton la santé la
mobilité deux éléments importants aussi
pour le duo soutenu par europe ecologie
les verts constitué de patricia mignot
et david lynch et on a comme projet de
permettre à tous les rangs boli teint et
tous les habitants du canton d'avoir
accès à un médecin à une pmi tout ce qui
est nécessaire localement et pas devoir
chercher des médecins jusqu'à trappe
parce que les nouveaux arrivants à
rambouillet ne trouve pas de médecin on
a une grosse problématique sur le sur le
bassin d'emploi de préservation et de
création d'emploi sur notre bassin de
vie et éviter que les personnes ne
soient obligés de faire des heures de
transport pour aller travailler
du côté du rassemblement national la
sécurité et l'enjeu le plus important de
cette départementale
d'autant que le 30 avril dernier un
attentat contre les forces de l'ordre
s'est produit à rambouillet c'est un
élément qui qui n'est pas nouveau
rassemblement national c'est la sécurité
c'est d'ailleurs le thème de jordan
bardella pour les régionales qui n'est
pas notre élection le choix de la
sécurité
voilà je pense que il est évident qu'on
ferait dans les collèges dans certains
collèges on ferait quand même quelqu'un
par là ça c'est certain mais justement
l'intérêt du département et de ses
budget qui ai l'argent des yvelinois
c'est de s'en servir à leur fin à leur
utilisation donc c'est tout à fait dans
l'esprit du rassemblement national et de
notre candidature bien sûr enfin la
dernière candidature sans étiquette
constitué de nathalie stéphane et
mickaël le saunier entend bien défendre
la ruralité et faire en sorte que les
villages du sud iv ne soit pas les
oubliés du département ça me semblait
important de poursuivre ce que j'ai
envie de faire c'est de remettre
l'humain au sein de l'action politique
aussi au niveau du département et
rajouter un peu plus de concertation et
d'implication des citoyens et des
acteurs locaux dans le département et
moi en parfaite complémentarité avec
nathalie stéphane moi je suis vraiment
pour
que le département prennent le virage du
développement durable et qu'aujourd'hui
on ait enfin une politique où le
développement durable n'est pas une
entité en soi mais surtout quelque chose
de transversales et qui intègre en fait
toutes les compétences du département
quatre binômes qui dévoileront au fur et
à mesure leurs programmes complets un
mois de campagne où les restrictions
sanitaires en vigueur contraindront les
candidats à trouver des solutions pour
couvrir au maximum le canton fin de ce
set 8 politique avoir en replay sur
notre site internet à suivre également
en replay et sur notre antenne notre
émission entretiens politiques je
recevrai prochainement nelly du tue tête
de liste yvelines aux régionales avec
clémentine autain et puis pour l'hebdo
politique lui nicolas kirillovitch il
recevra prochainement ghislaine ce n'est
la tête de liste yvelines europe
ecologie les verts avec julien bayou à
bientôt
[Musique]